สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงๆ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนนะคะครูฟ้าวันนี้วัน
อะไรคะกลับมาใช้เหมือนเดิมนะคะรู้สึกชิน
มือ
วันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 17
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกันยายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 17
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกันยายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 19
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกันยายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 10 โมง
10 โมงกี่นาที
27 นาทีค่ะ
ออสเตรเลียเป็นยังไงบ้างคะ
[เพลง]
ก็ประมาณ
ขอโทษนะคะทำไมเอ่อนานจังเลยค่ะ
23 องศาเซลเซียส
ที่
ประเทศไทยก็
มี 2 เลขเหมือนกันค่ะแต่ว่าสลับกันนะคะ
องศาเซลเซียสเห็นไหมคะมีเลข 3 เหมือนกัน
มีเลข 2 เหมือนกันนะคะแต่ว่าสลับกันนะคะ
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยอยู่ในห้องใช่ไหมในห้องใน
คอนโดเนี่ยนะคะ
ก็จะอยู่ในห้องใช่ไหมในห้องตรงนี้ก็จะ
เป็นประตูอยู่ในห้องเนี่ยโอ้โหร้อนมากๆ
คิดทำไมเดือนนี้เนี่ยเดือนกันยายนใช่ไหม
คะครูฟ้าทำไมมันร้อนเหมือนๆกับเดือน
เมษายนเลย
แต่ครูหญิงอยู่ในห้องทุกวันไงคะ
1 เดือนเนี่ยมี 30 วัน
ครูหญิงก็อยู่ในห้องประมาณ
28 วันแล้วอย่างนี้นักเรียนไม่ค่อยออกไป
ข้างนอกเพราะถ้าจะออกไปข้างนอกพอแต่พอ 1
วันเนี่ยได้ออกจากห้อง
ข้างนอกไม่ร้อนเหมือนในห้องนะ
ในห้องร้อนกว่าข้างนอกหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะเหมือนห้องของเราเนี่ยมีดวงอาทิตย์
เนี่ยค่ะมีพระอาทิตย์นะคะ
เยอะๆไงพระอาทิตย์เนี่ยส่องมายี่ห้อของ
ครูหญิงไงแล้วก็แบบทุกวันทุกวันผู้หญิงก็
ไม่ชอบออกไปข้างนอกเกลียดอ่ะค่ะครูฟ้า
ใช่เพราะว่าถ้าคุณหญิงจะออกไปข้างนอก
เนี่ยนะคะอันนี้เป็นคอนโดมิเนียมของครู
หญิงใช่ไหม
คอนโดมิเนียมเนี่ยมีหลายๆๆมีทั้งหมดเนี่ย
น่าจะชั้น 1 นะคะถึงชั้นที่ 29 ผู้หญิง
เนี่ยอยู่ชั้น 18 เวลาจะลงข้างล่างเนี่ย
จากชั้น 18 แล้วก็ลง
ชั้น 1
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงมันมี
ลิฟต์ไหม
ขี้เกียจลิปเนี่ยค่ะขี้เกียจรอลิฟต์
ผู้หญิงไม่ได้ลงบันไดไม่ใช่เหรอ
ไม่ใช่บันได
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ผู้หญิงจากชั้น 18 ลงมาชั้น 1
อยู่นะ
ทุกวันทุกวันเนี่ยนะคะผู้หญิงก็ใช้ลิป
เนี่ยแหละค่ะครูฟ้าแต่ว่าคอนโดคุย
มีลิฟท์อยู่ 2 ตัว
ไม่โอเคหรอ
ครูฟ้าถึงแม้ว่าจะเป็นวันจันทร์ถึงวัน
ศุกร์ที่คนไปทำงานแต่ก็ยังมีคนใช้ลิปเยอะ
นะบางครั้งต้องรอลิฟต์นานๆพอลิฟต์มาเนี่ย
นะคะข้างในลิฟต์เนี่ยก็มีคนเยอะมากๆ
มีคนคนอ้วน 4 คนเนี่ยน้อยมากนะคะในคอนโด
คุณหญิงเนี่ยก็จะมีคนมีคนมีคนมีคนมีคนมี
คนเยอะในลิฟต์
ผู้หญิงแล้วผู้หญิงทำยังไงอ่ะผู้หญิงเดิน
ลงบันไดไม่ได้เหรอ
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่ไปไงผู้หญิงก็หนึ่งอาทิตย์
ใช่ไหม 7 วันเนี่ยใน 1 อาทิตย์ 7 วันก็จะ
ออกไปข้างนอกนิดหน่อยแล้วก็จะดูเวลาคิด
ว่ามันจะมีเวลาประมาณ
11:00 นคนเยอะเวลาประมาณสักบ่ายสองโมง
เขียนผิดนะคะบ่ายสองโมงบ่าย 3 โมงอันนี้
ในลิฟท์ไม่มีคนไป
[เพลง]
ตั้งแต่ 7 โมงจนถึง 9 โมงเนี่ยโอ้โห
คนเยอะมากๆทุกคนไปออฟฟิศไงก็จะลงลิฟต์ใช่
ไหมคะแล้วก็ 11 โมง
ถึงบ่ายโมงก็คนเยอะเพราะว่าบางคนเนี่ย
สั่งอาหารเดลิเวอรี่ผ่าน Grab ก็จะลงไป
เอาอาหาร
ก็จะมีช่วงบ่าย 2 โมงบ่าย 3 โมงเนี่ยแหละ
ค่ะก็จะไม่มีคนอยู่ในลิฟต์ผู้หญิงก็จะ
อยู่คนเดียว
ผู้หญิงก็จะอยู่คนเดียวในลิฟท์ดีมากแล้ว
ก็รอลิฟท์นิดหน่อยเวลาที่ครูอยู่ในลิฟท์
เนี่ยนะคะครูฟ้าชอบอยู่คนเดียวแบบนี้นะ
หรือว่าชอบมีคนหลายๆคนในลิฟต์ค่ะครูฟ้า
ชอบอันไหนมากกว่ากัน
ครูฟ้าไม่ชอบลิฟต์ค่ะ
อ๋อ
ครูก็
ถ้าครูฟ้าอยู่คอนโดมิเนียม
ชั้นที่ 29 แล้วคุณฟ้าจะลงมาชั้น 1 เนี่ย
ครูฟ้าจะลงบันไดเหรอคะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ก็ไม่อยู่ชั้น 29 ไง
ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ชอบลิฟต์ทำไมอ่ะ
ครูฟ้าเคยอยู่ครูฟ้าเคยอยู่ที่ลิฟต์คน
เดียวหรอ
แล้วกลัวเหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะคุณฟ้ากลัวลิปนิดหน่อยนะคะ
มันไม่แข็งแรง
กลัวตายนะคะ
[เพลง]
ถ้าครูฟ้าต้องอยู่ในลิฟท์คนเดียวครูฟ้าจะ
รู้สึกยังไงอ่ะโอเคไหม
กลัวลิฟต์นิดหน่อย
ไม่ได้กลัวมาก
แต่ครูฟ้าชอบมีคนอยู่ด้วยมากกว่า
มีคนหนึ่งคน
หรือว่า 2 คน
ก็โอเค
แต่คุณคิดว่าหลายบางคนนะบางคนหลายๆคนก็
ได้ผู้หญิงแล้วกันนะคะผู้ชายเนี่ยถ้าเป็น
ผู้ชายผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันนะบางคน
อาจจะเหมือนผู้หญิงนะชอบอยู่ในลิฟต์คน
เดียวไม่เอาไม่เอาค่ะชอบอยู่ในลิฟท์คน
เดียวมากกว่าเวลาที่เราอยู่ในลิฟท์คน
เดียวเนี่ยทำอะไรได้หลายๆอย่างคิดว่ามากๆ
เลยนะคะถ้าผู้หญิงหลายๆคนเนี่ยอยู่ใน
ลิฟต์คนเดียว
ก็จะขายรูปเขาเรียกเซลฟี่ไหนอ่ะเป็น
เซลฟี่
เนี่ยลิปตรงนี้นะอย่างลิปในคอนโดคุณหญิง
เนี่ยข้างๆนี้ใช่ไหมข้างๆลิฟตรงนี้ค่ะมัน
จะเป็นกระจก
กระจกก็คือครูหญิงมองก็จะเห็นตัวเองที่
ที่นี่ใช่ไหมเป็นกระจกแบบส่องกระจกได้อ่ะ
ค่ะลิปของคอนโดคุณหญิงข้างหลังไม่มีนะแต่
ข้างๆเนี่ยข้างซ้ายแล้วก็ข้าง 2 ข้าง
เนี่ยก็เป็นกระจกไงบางครั้งถ้าเราอยู่ใน
ลิฟท์คนเดียวบางคนก็ถ่ายหยิบโทรศัพท์มา
แล้วก็ปิดหน้าตัวเอง
ว่าเวลาที่ลิฟต์ปิดลิฟท์บางที่เนี่ยถ้า
ปิดแล้วตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะ
มันก็เป็นกระจกเหมือนกันนะเป็นกระจกเพราะ
เราเซลฟี่เราก็จะเห็นตัวเองอย่างนี้ค่ะ
บางคนเนี่ยที่เขาอยู่คนเดียวเขาก็จะถ่าย
รูปเซลฟี่ไหมเขาเรียกเซลฟี่หรือแบบไม่ใช่
เนาะเซลฟี่มันต้องเห็นรถ
ก็ถ่ายรูปตัวเองไง
เออถ่ายรูปตัวเองนะคะที่กระจกไงถ้าอยู่คน
เดียวอ่ะ
ทำได้ถ่ายรูปตัวเองในลิฟท์แต่ถ้ามีคนอยู่
ด้วยมีคนอยู่ด้วยก็ไม่ได้ไงถ้าเราถ่ายก็
จะมีคนนี้เขาก็ไม่โอเคใช่ไหมคะเออใช่มัน
ก็ไม่โอเคไงอยู่คนเดียวก็โอเคนะคะ
ก็เลยเออนอกจากพี่ว่าเวลาที่เราอยู่ใน
ลิฟท์คนเดียวแล้วเราเนี่ยถ่ายรูปแล้วครู
ฟ้าคิดว่าเวลาคนอยู่ในลิฟท์คนเดียวแบบนี้
นะคะเราจะทำอะไรอีกอ่ะถ้าเป็นครูหญิงนะ
เอาครูหญิงก่อนนะคะที่ลิปในคอนโดครูหญิง
เนี่ยนะคะมีทีวีด้วยนะนักเรียนตรงเนี้ย
อเวนเจอร์
End  Game
ส่วนใหญ่เป็นอะไรนะ
เป็นโฆษณาแบบถ่ายโค้กขายเป๊ปซี่บอนชอนแบบ
นี้ก็มีนะไก่ทอดร้านอาหารเอานักเรียน
กูฟาร์คิดดูว่าตั้งแต่ชั้น 1 นะคะขึ้นมา
ถึงชั้นที่ 18 เนี่ยประมาณ
กี่นาที 2-3 นาทีได้ไหม
เร็วไงไม่ได้เร็วมากๆเออมันจะขึ้นแบบ
ช้าๆอย่างนี้ค่ะก็ในลิฟต์มีทีวีบางทีเรา
ไม่มีอะไรทำก็ดูทีวีได้อ่า
อยู่แต่อยู่ในลิฟต์เนี่ยดูทีวีเนี่ยคน
เดียวก็ได้หลายๆคนก็ดูได้มีคนอยู่ในลิฟต์
เยอะๆก็ดูได้เพราะว่ามันแค่มองเฉยๆไง
นึกว่าดูหนังดูซีรีส์นะในทีวีไม่ทำให้
ขนาดนั้นนะคะ
คือยังไงนะอยู่ในลิฟท์หรอ
ถ้าอยู่ในลิฟท์คนเดียวนะคะ
คนจะทำอะไร
นี่คืออะไรคะ
นักเรียน
70% น่ะ
คนที่อยู่ในลิฟท์คนเดียวนะคะกด
อันนี้คือเป็นแก๊สเหม็นๆใช่ไหมคะที่ออกมา
จากก้นของเรา
ตดเออใช่ค่ะอันนี้คิดว่าไม่รู้ว่าประเทศ
นักเรียนเป็นยังไงนะคะแต่คนไทยคนไทยหลายๆ
คนเนี่ยถ้าพูดถึงอยู่ในลิฟท์คนเดียวตดค่ะ
นักเรียนคนเดียวไง
ว่าไม่ตดในลิฟต์นะคะผู้หญิง
มันเหม็น
เราอยู่คนเดียวอ่ะเราจะทำทำไมมันเหม็นน่ะ
แต่ถ้าบางครั้งเรามีแก๊สอยู่ในท้องจริงๆ
ไงครูฟ้าถ้าเราต้องเก็บใช่ไหมจนถึง
อพาร์ทเม้นท์จนถึงห้องของเราถ้ามีคนอยู่
ในลิฟท์หลายคนเราต้องเก็บเอาไว้นะคะแต่
ถ้าไม่มีคนไม่มีคนเราอยู่คนเดียวก็ปล่อย
ได้นะคะ
[เพลง]
สบายนะคะ
เหม็นนะ
เราตดเราก็เหม็น
นะนักเรียนเพราะงั้นออกไปข้างนอกแล้วค่อย
ตดดีกว่า
ครูฟ้าจะไม่ทำใช่ไหมแต่อาจจะมีคนหลายๆที่
ทำ
ใช่ค่ะ
ไหมคะ
นักเรียนไม่ Comment
ไม่เป็นไรอดมีอย่างอื่นอีกไหมผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าอันนี้เพราะเห็นแล้วผู้หญิง
ก็เออใช่ๆๆอันนี้คุณหญิงก็เคยทำนะคะอย่าง
ที่คุณหญิงบอกว่าลิปในคอนโดคุณหญิงเนี่ย
ตรงนี้นะคะข้างๆเนี่ยมันก็จะเป็นกระจก
กระจกใช่ไหมเวลาที่ครูหญิงอยู่ที่ลิฟท์คน
เดียวก็จะส่องกระจกอันนี้ไม่ใช่หันหน้า
แบบนี้นะนักเรียนก็จะหันหน้ามาทางนี้นะคะ
อันนี้ผมนะคะนี่ก็จะส่องกระจกไงอย่างเช่น
สมมุติถ้าวันนี้ครูหญิงเนี่ยเขียนคิ้วทา
ปากทาแก้มแล้วก็กำลังจะลงไปข้างล่างออกไป
ข้างนอกใช่ไหมคะถ้าอยู่ในลิฟต์คนเดียวนี่
คนนี้นะอ่าก็จะดูส่องกระจกว่าเอ๊ะน่าเรา
เป็นยังไงโอเคไหม
ว่าถ้าอยู่สองคน
ก็ไม่ส่องใช่ไหมคะอายอายคนนี้ไงเพราะบาง
ทีเราก็จะส่องแล้วก็ดูแบบดูตาดูฟันดูจมูก
ดูผม
ส่องกระจกนะครูฟ้าทำไหมคะเวลาครูฟ้าอยู่
ในลิฟต์แล้วลิฟต์มีกระจกครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะ
ครูฟ้าส่องกระจกในลิฟต์ไหม
มันก็ automatic นะนักเรียนพอเห็นกระจก
ส่องกระจกไง
ดูใช่ไหมคะดูเช็คตัวเองไง
ทุกคนก็จะมองกระจกก่อนไหม
[เพลง]
เพราะว่าร้องเพลง
ผู้หญิงก็ทำนะคะนักเรียนบางทีอยู่ในอยู่
ในเดี่ยวร้องเพลงนะ
แต่ลืมนะคะลิปในคอนโดคุณหญิงเนี่ยที่นี่
มี CCTV นะ
มีกล้อง CCTV นะคะแล้วที่ชั้น 1 เนี่ยมี
ทีวีอยู่ข้างล่างแล้วก็มี Security เนี่ย
นั่งดู
ในลิฟต์แต่ครูหญิงก็ร้องเพลงในลิฟต์นะแต่
อาจจะเบาๆเนาะ
ร้องเพลง
ครูฟ้าร้องเพลงในลิฟต์ไหมคะ
ก็มีบ้างค่ะ
เขานั่งดูดูกล้องในลิฟต์แต่เขาก็ไม่ได้
นั่งดูแบบนี้ไงนักเรียนแต่เขาก็ดูนะคะเรา
เต้นก็ธรรมดาเนาะไม่เป็นไรนะคะร้องเพลง
เขาก็ไม่ได้ยินนะคะไม่ได้ยิน
ก็ไม่เป็นไรเห็นมั้ย
ใช่ก็เต้นได้ร้องเพลงได้หรือว่าคิดว่าน่า
รักที่สุดเลยเนี่ย
90% ของคนที่อยู่ในลิฟต์
อาจจะยังไม่ใช่มากที่สุดแล้วกัน 9 เอาไม่
เอา 90% เอา 85% ดีกว่าเพราะเดี๋ยวมันมี
อีกอันนึงคิดว่า 85% ของคนที่อยู่ในลิฟต์
นะคะไม่ว่าจะอยู่ในลิฟต์คนเดียวหรือว่า
อยู่หลายๆคนก็คือเล่นโทรศัพท์
แน่นอน
หรือว่าบางคนก็คุยโทรศัพท์ด้วยนะ
คือถ้าอยู่ในนี้คนเดียว
บางที่มันคุยได้นะ
หลายๆคนก็คุยโทรศัพท์อันนี้ไม่โอเคนะ
เสียงดังเสียงดัง
เราก็คุยโทรศัพท์โอเคนะคะแต่ถ้าที่คุณ
หญิงบอกว่าอันนี้อันดับที่ 2 ใช่มั้ยคุย
โทรศัพท์คิดว่าอันดับที่ 1 นะคะ number
one อยู่ในลิฟท์คนเดียวเลยอาจจะก้าว 19%
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าอะไร
กูพาคิดว่า
หลับไหม
1%
หลับในลิฟท์ไม่ค่ะครูฟ้า 99% ก็คือไม่ทำ
อะไรอยู่ในลิฟต์คนเดียวก็ยืนเฉยๆไงมันทำ
อะไร
เล่นโทรศัพท์ไม่ส่องกระจกใช่ไหมกระจกตรง
นี้ไม่ส่องกระจกไม่ร้องเพลงหรือว่าไม่ตด
ออกมาเหมือนที่ครูฟ้าบอกนะคะไม่ทำอะไรก็
ยืนเฉยๆแล้วก็รอลิฟต์ไปเฉยๆ
ก็เหมือนลิปบางที่มันเร็วมากอย่างเงี้ย 1
นาทีก็ถึงแล้วบางทีก็ไม่ทำอะไรไงบางคนก็
กลัวไงต้องดูลิฟต์กับมันขึ้นขึ้น
ปกติอย่างเงี้ยค่ะ
เนาะก็เอามาคุยให้ฟังสนุกๆนะคะเราเวลาที่
อยู่ในลิฟท์คนเดียวนักเรียนชอบทำอะไรก็
คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้นะคะส่วนวีดีโอนี้ผู้
หญิงกับป๋าไปก่อนเนาะแล้วเดี๋ยวเราเจอกัน
ใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะ